[Music]
[Applause]
last year a certain place in my city
Jakarta was attacked by suicide bomber
let's imagine this event happen inside a
superhero comic book the villain in this
case the side bomber arrives at the
scene he walks around surveying the
people and the place once is settled all
he needs to do is press this little red
button and boom everything blows up
people running away kids are screaming
police and ambulance sirens can be heard
from every direction suddenly the
superhero with his cape or her shining
armor
comes and saved today they helps put
civilians to safety puts out the fire
takes the injured to hospital and most
importantly defeats the villain we all
of these stories don't we we all grow up
hearing stories of heroism especially
superheroes how Captain America with all
his loyalty and super strength he can
save the world and win the hearts of
everyone and how Batman is in all his
money he creates super gadgets to save
his city Gotham tell me who doesn't love
them who doesn't dream to be saved by
them even though you know they're
fictional admit it all of you must have
dreamt about it but those heroes The
Avengers Batman Superman they have their
own place to be hero they have their own
stories where they put up their shining
armor or capes or tights and you know
save the world but in the end they are
only stories they don't exist in the
real world in the real world we'll live
in so who then are the everyday heroes
among us they don't wear capes or tights
or having superpowers so what do they
look like the dictionary says a hero is
someone who is admired for their
courage noble qualities and outstanding
achievements but to me I think that
heroes are people who have the courage
to help other people as simple as that
it can be if the person just smile at
stranger to me that is an act of heroism
why because we never know what the
person might be going through and
smiling at stranger takes some strength
and effort it takes effort to put aside
our doubts at smiling at stranger it
takes strength to have to share the same
feelings with others to have empathy
there are a lot of heroes in real life
like Malala Abraham Lincoln Martin
Luther King Sukarno indonesia's first
president and a whole bunch of others
and if I ask you what made them a hero
most of us will say let's take an
example Malala most of us will say she's
a hero because she fights for a girls
education she is a hero because she
sacrificed herself or maybe other
example Martin Luther King he's a hero
because he fought for freedom for people
of color she fought for this he fought
for that and the whole list goes on but
really though let's take a moment and
think about it all the heroes I just
mentioned and the and the heroes we all
know is help other people Malala helped
girls to have education Martin Luther
King helped people of color to gain
greater freedom and equality in United
States they all believe in equality and
that everyone should get the same
chances they have visions to make this
world a better place you see as we grew
up we realized that life is much harder
and tougher than it looks
and we humans we are social creatures we
need each other in order to survive we
need each other
in order to live we need each other to
be our heroes héroes comes in different
shapes and sizes we don't
need to have superpowers to be heroes we
don't need to have a lot of money to be
heroes we don't need to stand in front
of a gun to be hero we don't need to
sacrifice our self to death to be a hero
but we do have to be kind to be hero we
have to be helpful to be hero we have to
be empathetic to be hero we have to do
all these things and other good things
to be hero these traits seem simple but
it actually takes time to practice so
what if we start practicing for the day
when we can be hero
what if we had a hero training going
back to what happened in Jakarta last
year I think that no matter how long we
waited for that super hero with his cape
or her shining armor to come they
wouldn't because the real hero in this
event was in them it was the people who
decided fear Wilden brought him down and
helped other people instead I used to
think of my hero as Superman and Batman
trust me no joke I have this huge photo
frame filled my filled with my photos
and theirs and then as I get older I
stare at it and think I think that there
are more people who have been there for
me through it all and the thing about
life it has its own up and down in which
there some moment we feel like stopping
maybe like throwing up but there is
someone who shared the same ride with me
through my ups and down and that is my
mother she have no cape no superpowers
no exploding bank account she's just
another human being but she's there for
me she guided me and she helped me she
is the reason I am standing here today
so can I say that she is my hero yes I
can
I look around at how I might become a
hero and the best example I could find
wasn't wearing a cape it was my mother
she's a hero because she's there for me
to rely on she's a hero because she's
there for me to wipe away my tears she's
a hero because she is there for me to
make me smile this is just one story
that we can take into our hero training
and I wanted to figure out this hero
formula so that I can share with y'all
so I did an experiment I spent three
days looking for hero makers here's what
I saw one day my friend was crying in
class people around her was telling her
to get over it
you know to stop think about it it
doesn't matter you're overreacting but
then this other friend came to her and
gave her a hug a support no advice no
talking talking just support that's your
lesson number one heroes are always
looking out for others my friend didn't
tell her what she should feel because to
be honest the only one who knows what it
truly feel is my friend who is crying so
instead she thought about what might she
needed at that moment that's empathy the
second example is my school nurse was
walking down the street with her baby
and a toddler beside her she struggled
to put everything onto her motorbike but
then when she should finally managed to
put her children in she almost dropped
her bag until a men came to her and
decided to help her
that's your lesson number two it's
sometimes it doesn't require a great
action to be a hero small gesture like
that deserve to be called a hero action
there are a lot more stories you can
learn from and we can add into our hero
training but there is one lesson that I
learn from these events and that is
sometimes the small gesture are the one
that mattered the most it is the way we
smile at others that makes us a hero
because we never know maybe
smile was the only good thing they had
that day it was the way we hug our
family and friends that makes us a hero
it is the way we give a hand to others
when they needed help with their
groceries and it's the way we make
somebody else smile that makes us a hero
so I think that being here a hero is
it's all about having a lot of many or
wearing capes or ring shining armor and
do great things and changing the world I
think that being a hero is about being
kind helpful generous and empathetic
these are the things we should do in our
hero training these are the things we
should do in our daily life as a good
human being and as a hero now we can all
start training today do you want to be
your version of Captain kindness or
maybe you want to have your own
empathetic mobile like Batman or maybe
it can be everything by yourself and be
an Avenger it is all up to you if the
answer to this question is yes then you
know what you have to do go out there
pick a color of your cape and be a hero
thank you
[Applause]